pensons être tout proche de la date
limite ce couple de bisontins préféré
prendre ses précautions pour s'inscrire
[Musique]
on pensait que c'était jusqu'au 31
décembre la date limite au fait pour le
changement
qu'est ce qui a motivé votre démarche
c'est un changement d'adressé
visiblement oui un changement d adresse
à ce que les élections municipales car
il et puis que c'est important de voter
voilà en cas de déménagement vous devez
donc engager une nouvelle démarche
alors je vous remets déjà votre
attestation changement d'adressé début
mars 2020 vous allez recevoir une
nouvelle carte électorale et vous allez
recevoir sous plein jour une
notification d'inscription sur la liste
voilà bah c'est tout bon mais dans
d'autres cas l'inscription est désormais
automatique
une série va inscrire automatiquement
les jeunes majeurs mais uniquement les
jeunes majeurs qui ont été recensés donc
vigilance quand même aux jeunes qui ont
18 ans de vérifier sur le site service
public.fr qu'ils ont bien été recensée
et inscrit sinon il faut qu'ils le
fassent néanmoins autre information
devenir majeur entre les deux tours
permettent de voter au second tour si
vous devez passer par la case
inscription vous avez donc encore de la
marge
depuis la mise en oeuvre du registre
électoral unique vous pouvez vous
inscrire un exemple les élections
municipales jusqu'au 7 février minuit en
ligne 17h30 à l'accueil de la mairie
si vous n'êtes pas en mesure de voter
n'oubliez pas de faire établir une
procuration
cette fois ci il faudra vous adresser au
commissariat ou à la gendarmerie a voté